[Music]
well the Olympics are coming up soon and
you know what that means time to care
about some sports that we don't have to
care about for another four years one of
those sports is purling hello I'm here
with Bob and Sean Ryan Ryan I'm here
with Bob and you guys are part of the
Orange County curling club that's
correct yes so let's just briefly go
over the basics of curling because
sometimes it looks like you know some
kind of weird icy yoga the name of the
game is to slide these stones all the
way down the ice to the opposite house
and get more of your rocks into that
house than the opposing team do you
think you you are one who brooms or one
who throws I barely know you
there's a question for my white sir
there we go never lease
it's hard now why can't I just do this
there's one thing in my intimate areas
that isn't torn down
there we go that looks great oh let's
like make the house nice shot
[Applause]
what not accomplishes so for sweeping
you want to sweep the path of the rock
and you want to push down as hard as you
can and you want to sweep as fast as you
can okay be an effective sweeper and to
make it even more fun
your skip will be yelling at you rice
wheat corn not to speak so you don't
make any decisions on your own you just
do as you're told
yes boy I know how the happiness
good sweeping boys that positive
affirmation of life
yeah comes from speaking and basically
it's like scrubbing my patio I learned
all I need to know I've got all the
tools in my possession and it's time to
get curling or get what do you say curl
it's let's curl
[Music]
[Music]
roll the rock as you ascend to the top
find your destiny and vanquish all your
Bibles
[Music]
[Music]
don't survive
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right the match is pretty tense
we're down to the last rock or stone or
whatever the other team's winning
they're closer to the nipple I believe
this is fall knock them out of here to
win and if we don't we'll lose
yes oh I missed by a long shot
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]